je cite une victime faut que je fouille
dans ta culotte tu es sale ça me dégoûte
tu sens mauvais je vais te fouiller dans
la chatte
qui a bien pu dire ça en glissant la
main dans les parties génitales d'une
jeune étudiante des prédateurs sexuels
des criminels il s'agit de policier lors
d'une fouille au corps mardi dernier
dans ma circonscription
4 jeunes femmes ont porté plainte une
enquête de l'IGPN est ouverte ma
première question est simple monsieur le
ministre rendez-vous hommage à ses
agents ou sanctionner vous c'est
pratique et allez vous le surprendre les
agents pour de la durée de l'enquête il
s'agit de votre responsabilité monsieur
le ministre partout en France les faits
sont accablants déplacements en garde à
vue sans motif se multiplie rien que
jeudi soir 292 interpellations 283 ont
été classés sans suite hier 300
interpellations combien de jours encore
continuerez-vous à organiser la
détention arbitraire de notre pays
dans un moment d'une contestation
politique et sociale largement soutenue
votre réponse c'est le nassage le
matraquage les bombes de désencerclement
et les tirs tendus comme vous je
voudrais avoir un mot pour c394
policiers et gendarmes blessés
[Applaudissements]
faut dire également que depuis six jours
les policiers et les gendarmes font face
et je les dis tout à l'heure à 1500 1500
opérations non déclarées et je veux
d'ailleurs dire aujourd'hui qu'il n'est
pas dans l'État de droit de s'en prendre
à des bâtiments publics de saccager des
mairies
de mettre le feu à des préfectures
[Applaudissements]
de jeter des cocktails Molotov sur les
gendarmes et sur les policiers et je
vous remercie de soutenir ces personnes
qui sont de véritables ouvriers de la
sécurité vous comparez des dégradations
bâtiments à des violences sexistes et
sexuelles nous nous habiterons jamais à
votre invité Monsieur je voudrais ici
d'ailleurs vous rappeler que saisissant
des enquêtes de l'IGPN de l'hygiène
elles sont conduites sous les procureurs
de la République et que chacun devrait
respecter la justice
[Applaudissements]